So our gathering today has a name and it's called Your Sins Are Forgiven.
Now, you might find that a bit abrupt.
Like, why are you talking about my sins being forgiven the very first time we meet?
But there's a picture next to me, a photo.
Photo.
And that photo is actually from this book here.
I don't know if you can see this book I'm holding in my hand right now.
Now, I don't think many people can read this book because it's written in Nepali.
I bought it in Kathmandu.
And it actually tells a story about Jesus when he was on earth, which we'll have a chance to talk about in a bit.
So, having just heard from Kili and Syfy, I wonder if you envy the changes in their lives.
It reminds me of this verse in the Bible, which says,
It is God who arms me with strength and keeps my way secure.
the god we know today is not just some abstract concept